[Musique]
une centaine de mètres à peine séparent
la chine continentale et hong kong de
part et d'autre des grillages des
familles des amis se donnent rendez vous
ici pour s'apercevoir quelques instants
joyeux anniversaire
certains ne se sont pas retrouvés depuis
des années depuis le début de la
pandémie et la fermeture des frontières
ce hongkongais ne sait pas quand il sera
réuni avec sa femme et son fils de
l'autre côté
je te vois
quand est-ce que tu rentres à la maison
lui travaille à shenzhen côté chinois
mais sa famille vite à hong kong avant
la pandémie il pouvait passer la
frontière toutes les semaines
aujourd'hui il est bloqué ici on fait
des appels vidéo mais ce n'est rien
comparé au fait de les voir en personne
ça fait trop longtemps que je suis loin
de ma famille il me manque vraiment
pour rentrer en chine ces trois semaines
de quarantaine pour environ 1000 euros
aux frais du voyage air impossible pour
ce quarantenaire de faire des
allers-retours un crève coeur nécessaire
selon lui il faut le faire c'est pour le
monde entier pour nous mêmes et pour le
pays je suis d'accord avec ces mesures
il faut juste faire un peu de sacrifice
des sacrifices la chine en fait beaucoup
au nom de sa politique zéro co vide ici
pas question de vivre avec le virus et
ça marche officiellement le pays contre
moins de 6000 morts depuis le début de
la pandémie au moindre cas positifs les
autorités test confine et tracent la
moindre menace dans la ville de chengdu
les cas contacts sont même repéré grâce
à leurs téléphones avec les données de
localisation surveiller il suffit de se
trouver pendant dix minutes à moins de
800 mètres d'une personne positive pour
être envoyés en quarantaine en novembre
pour une dizaine de cas qu vide 82 mille
personnes deviennent suspecte dépistage
massif et quarantaine obligatoire des
mesures approuvées par les habitants ces
mesures étaient indispensables
parce que toutes les vies sont
précieuses et doivent être protégés
c'était compliqué mon quartier étaient
bloqués mais il n'y avait pas le choix
selon moi c'était pour s'assurer de la
sécurité de tout le monde et pour
empêcher que le virus ne se répande
c'était très efficace
cette efficacité redoutable à un prix la
paralysie comme hassiane dans le nord du
pays pour environ 200 cas au 23 décembre
13 millions d'habitants sont confinées
jusqu'à nouvel ordre la ville entière et
désinfecter sauf pour aller se faire
tester interdiction de mettre un pied
dehors même pas pour faire des courses
les résidents sont ravitaillés par les
comités de quartier mais les autorités
reconnaissent des problèmes
d'approvisionnement sur les réseaux
sociaux les habitants crient leur faim
vous avez quoi manger moi j'ai trop faim
j'ai rien rien
la lutte contre le coc vida priorité
absolue avec parfois des méthodes chocs
allant jusqu'à l'humiliation publique
ces quatre hommes menottés sont accusés
d'avoir aidé des étrangers à passer la
frontière entre le vietnam et la chine
leurs photos et leurs noms autour du cou
la police locale les fait défiler pour
l'exemple cette parade de la honte est
vite condamné par certains médias
officiels et certains internautes les
critiques contre la politique zéro co
vides sont pourtant rares même si ces
mesures draconiennes pourrait faire
perdre un point de croissance annuelle à
la chine exception notable cette
interview d'un éminent virologue chinois
à la télévision hongkongaise nous ne
devrions pas faire des tests à grande
échelle systématiquement si le
gouvernement persiste avec la politique
zéro co vite pour quelques cas je pense
que l'économie de notre pays en
souffrira c'était sans compter
l'apparition de mikron pour les
autorités chinoises l'extrême
contagiosité du nouveau variant leur
donne raison
certains pays ont réagi dès que quelques
cas omicron ont été repérés en prenant
des mesures administratives très
strictes au regard de notre expérience
au cours des deux dernières années
la méthode chinoise est la bonne et elle
pourrait encore se durcir face à omicron
une gageure pour les entreprises
étrangères implantées en chine qui peine
à recruter à l'extérieur les visas sont
accordés au compte gouttes et de plus en
plus d'expatriés quittent le pays coupé
du monde rien qu'à shanghai des
centaines de cadres attendent leurs
visas depuis des mois mais certaines
sociétés en profitent pour se concentrer
sur le marché intérieur comme sept
agences de communication françaises
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
donc en février 2020 on a une croissance
de l'activité en chine continentale
d'environ 30% voire 40% on a dû
également avoir une augmentation de la
masse salariale depuis deux ans tous les
nouveaux employés sont chinois un
avantage selon le directeur le fait
d'avoir plus d'employés locaux cela nous
apporte plus de connaissances plus de
compréhension et plus de savoir-faire
sur qu'est ce que c'est que le marché
local et la culture locale les
frontières pourrait rester fermé encore
longtemps selon les estimations les plus
optimistes
la chine ne devrait pas rouvrir avant au
moins un an